deux ans de travail vingtaine de granit
sont déplacés aujourd'hui dans le
quartier du pont du route voire à
guyancourt l'oeuvre de grigory gicquel
et daniel dewar a été sélectionné par
les nouveaux commanditaires de
guyancourt les nouveaux commanditaires
est un processus organisé par la
fondation de france qui permet donc un
financement fondation france bien sûr
mais aussi avec une médiatrice de
pouvoir discuter de créer un cahier des
charges et à ce moment là de développer
le projet avec les différents
partenaires donc bien sûr la ville des
habitants
et puis nous on a aussi des mécènes et
des mêmes des commerçants qui en
participer à ce projet nathalie
habitants du quartier à participer au
projet et à la commande de la sculpture
contacté par la mairie
elle a accepté d'être une des
commanditaires pour le patrimoine de sa
ville nous avons eu différentes réunions
où nous a expliqué le principe de la
commande faite par des habitants auprès
d'artistes et c'est quelque chose auquel
nous sommes pas familier en tout cas
pour ma part je n'étais pas et j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant d'autant plus
que nous y étions accompagnés par une
médiatrice anxieux mais ravis de pouvoir
installer son oeuvre intitulée le rocher
le lièvre et le banc
grégory gicquel a respecté le cahier des
charges avec son collaborateur pour que
la sculpture se fondent dans le quartier
nous avons proposé un projet on a eu un
cahier des charges qui était axé un peu
sur la nature sur l'histoire de
guyancourt
donc on leur a proposé cette oeuvre qui
est complètement lié aussi à notre
propre travail
une oeuvre qui se voulait utile grâce au
banc inclus mais aussi agréable
visuellement la sculpture respecte donc
les envies des habitants du quartier qui
vont pouvoir à présent l'admirer de plus
près